hey everyone welcome back to GameSpot I
am Mike I am here with the creative
director at Cappy this is Chris
piotrowski and you just as of like right
before we start recording announced a
release date before the game yes yeah
it's coming out next week on the 14th
yep and we just mounts a trailer and so
it's been a long time coming and I'm
feeling a little bit nervous and answer
crawling all over my body right yeah as
in over five years you know there's a
little bit of time before that as well
and prototyping it's really early stages
of the game
yeah and but yeah it's been it's been a
it's been a long haul for sure so it's
nice to have it coming together now and
yeah looking forward to the release even
though I am personally going through an
emotional turmoil hopefully that shakes
out well but uh yeah I'm glad you
brought the gamin so we've got the game
we kind of skipped over you said like a
four-minute ish intro with starting from
the beach yes at the beginning we just
sort of skipped the this the kind of
intro moments just because it's it's a
nice little sailing sequence that
probably plays better in your living
room in the middle of the night than it
does on a twitch stream when you want to
see some cool stuff so so yeah we're
beginning the game almost at the
beginning this is the South Shore of the
island that where the game whole game
takes place inside the subterranean
depths of this world so it's it's just a
little bit past the beginning gotcha
and so yeah like you've shown the game a
lot throughout the past five years in
varying states of completion or lack
thereof but for those who don't know
what's like the elevator pitch for below
below is sort of like a combination of
wrote like sort of dungeon-crawling
mixed with a little bit of like a Zelda
style adventure game Adventure World
design so it's not a hundred percent
procedurally generated it has randomly
generated dungeons that kind of
interconnect into like little pockets of
handcrafted little space that they can
find and discover them that are found
within those randomly generated moments
I've also described it and we were sort
of our little tagline is a solitary
journey through the haunted depths of a
forbidden Isle there you go so that's
the game yeah that's it but as far as
the kind of game that it is it heavily
leans on roguelikes although I guess I
should probably call it a roguelike like
before a bunch of it I think I get very
angry
rogue fans work well I've been receiving
it yeah yeah well yeah as far as the
structure of the game goes it's it's not
completely randomly generated sort of
like if you imagine a game like
Minecraft where every time you play you
get a new seed and there's a whole new
world for you to explore that you know
as a whole different flow this game is
Israeli generated in this sort of way
that a game like Diablo or or spelunky
is where okay you know the game has a
very specific sort of layer-cake
structure of zones share with levels and
stuff like that and all those levels are
randomized but but you will pass through
sort of the same layer cake as better
but the the structure of it
like the inner details of it or our our
brand new every time you die gotcha
now I was gonna say like spelunky is one
of those that comes to mind just because
literally you're going from the surface
deeper yes yeah at least they're out for
when I've seen it below as I guess as
well as like rogue itself they exactly
it's it's a very it's a totally classic
structure yeah diabla is the same thing
it's like go down until you meet the
baddie yeah
so that's right he said that's like a
lantern oh yeah yeah so what I'm just
sort of mentioned what I'm doing right
now being in the game you find this
object called the lantern and the
lantern is sort of the game's it's the
main sort of quest item so I kind of
describe it as blows a Carina of time in
that the whole game is sort of built
around this magical object called the
lantern that I find at the very surface
of the Isle and one of the kind of big
ideas in the game has all sort of
interconnects is every single time you
die in below you start as a brand new
wanderer arriving on the islands after
the previous waters life so the game
world itself the progress that you
making it is is persistent but the lives
themselves are fleeting and short and
and fragile so the game really isn't
necessarily about having one character
that becomes more powerful and you know
becomes kind of like the monster killing
machine but it's really about making a
little bit of progress with each life
and building on top of that the one
thing about it though is that the
lantern itself is a specific unique item
in the game and I describe it as sort of
like the guiding lights for the player
it's all it's the way it works is that
if you if you go into the world with one
wanderer who has the lantern and they
die the lantern has dropped at their
corpse and the only way to retrieve the
lantern is to just to fight your way
back to it okay so the game kind of goes
back and forth between these two modes
where
you know at some one moment you do have
this lantern and it's it's helpful it
provides lights it it illuminates
important details it helps you recognize
traps and dangers and things like that
and then inevitably
you lose that lantern you have to go
back into the world without it and then
that's when the systems that are built
around like crafting torches and other
sources of light become super important
as I the game when you have Lantern the
game's a little bit safer a little bit
easier to play and it's sort of like
giving you just a little bit more
information but at some point you do
lose that guiding light and if there's a
hard journey to get back to it yeah it's
kind of like the baton that's shared
between lives right and every characters
is trying to or every Wanderers trying
to just get back to that that lantern
and take it deeper and deeper into the
game all right
so from what I play the game and from
what I've kind of become known for it
doesn't seem to hold your hand much you
know it's very much up to us to figure
out what we're doing where we're going
kind of it's not very I mean I don't
maybe there was stuff in the beginning
but I don't think there was like in
terms of tutorials you're kind of
learning as you go right there really is
no tutorials in the game we have some
little things that like at the beginning
we kind of you know we show you like hey
this is the button that makes the
Lantern glow okay and like little hints
like that but beyond that the game is
really designed to be kind of like
a closed puzzle box my hope is that I
kind of feel like humans or take a lot
of pleasure and you know the human mind
is really good at recognizing patterns
and and figuring out systems it's
something that I think gamers kind of do
inherently yeah and I know Kay I'm
interested in the idea of giving players
a game where it says nothing yeah and
the whole thing is just like a big giant
puzzle box that you need to figure out
how to unlock as you go and I there is
something scary about that idea
obviously because I think players these
days are kind of a lot of games do hold
hands quite a bit and I'm not knocking
that in anyway I think that's totally
great I play those games and love them
but but I think there's there's room
I think there's there are players who
who are looking for and and would
appreciate something that's a little bit
quieter and sort of says hey this is on
you you're on your own here sure I've
always found out when I when I done with
this game at PAX and stuff like that if
I mentioned like hey the game has no
hints and has no no dialogue and no text
that players were to be like okay and
then they just sort of lean into the
game and try to figure it out
how sick are you of Dark Souls
comparisons oh I'm not sick of it at all
I think like Dark Souls the entire Dark
Souls series came out during this
development what are you really okay did
you think of that yeah but I don't know
I think I think that Dark Souls is is a
really interesting like I don't think
below has I don't think the below is
below hasn't been designed to be as as
as difficult when it comes to combat and
stuff like that right but I think the
approach at Dark Souls had where it sort
of you know confidently let players
loose in the world and then you know
knew that they're gonna learn through
trial and error and through dying quite
a bit and just ends you know being kind
of confidence' to create a design like
that it's interesting because like one
of the things is that like the Dark
Souls structure and game design is one
of the reasons why that game found such
a such an amazing community right people
immediately when the game came out began
to talk to each other like where is this
how do you get that what's the best way
to do this where is this piece of armour
and all that information came from the
community not from you know the game
itself just sort of telling you hey your
things over there this is where the
thing is it just it's a game that where
everything's just there it's sitting
there for you to try to you know figure
out how to get there and just discover
things through exploration so that like
at the forefront of your minds when
you're creating below as far as kind of
creating something that people people
would talk about and share and discover
things in that kind of yeah I think dark
with a nice thing about Dark Souls is
that yeah it did it did give us a bit of
confidence in the idea that you can make
a game that has like a that's very
difficult and very very dense and
mechanics and and then just let players
like knowing that players will work
together and and and that kind of thing
does engage players in that way where
you know somebody finds something and
then they go on for and share it and
then eventually like you know people
start playing with the Wikipedia of gun
and stuff like that like when I played
don't start we're like when I play
minecraft I remember like early on just
having like the player made like the fan
with wiki and and learning from that so
there's something there's definitely
something in below that you know we
designed it kind of intentionally to
to try to capture that we're really you
don't know anything aside from the
game's called below and you're going
down yeah go down try to go as far down
as you can but outside from that the
mechanics the you know the theme of the
game narrative it's all kind of just a
little secret sure but I do assume that
you know day one sorry I like he over
had a vertical jump attack reminds me
the z-targeting attack from ocarina
yeah the combat was inspired not not
necessarily by Dark Souls but by by
winwaker okay for me winwaker is like
the pinnacle of fun feeling snappy ii
sort of technical combat that has like a
nice playful feel to it that makes me
feel like a little like lincoln when do
in winwaker feels like a little ninja
that can do little backflips and every
little move is is just right right with
least abs ganon right before how that it
would be a greatest thing in the world
it was but yeah I can definitely see
winwaker in this yeah so the move set
that you have in combat is very similar
to to win wickley you've got like a
little like a regular head you can hold
your shield and stab around like this
the sort this the shield can be moved
around but if you don't touch the
artistic you can strafe okay there's a
little shield bash there's like a
running lunge and a couple of there's
like a dodge roll as well
so the sword and shield is is very much
like the bread and butter of the game
but then I decided from that you do have
a bow with a bunch of arrows that you
can craft and and throughout the game
you do find armor and masks and and
two-handed weapons but yeah the the
combat hat was very much influenced by
the feel of winwaker where that has that
kind of like for me winwaker is like a
more playful easier to to get into
version of like all the same moves that
Dark Souls has kind of right so that's
that's been my influence that was all
that for me is my one true love I'm
doing a little bit of crafting here so I
in between I just finished the first
level of the game
and in between levels there's these
little quiet spaces for you to to sort
of take the resources that you found in
the game and and convert them into soups
or potions or take the materials and
turn them into tools like torch or
band-aid and stuff like that okay so in
between each level there's like a little
bit of prep basically any other thing is
that the fire pits can be used if you
spend crystals which are in top right
corner you can use them to mark a fire
pit for a shortcut okay so and it's just
it's not like it's not a permanent one
it's just it's like it's one saving
grace basically so for example if I
right now go into the next level and die
because I I mark that that fire the next
life we'll be able to teleport there
from any fire gotcha
but it's just like a 1/1 it's a one-time
use sort of thing okay so it's sort of
like one chance to get back to your
corpse one chance to get back to your
right
your lantern before you have to do it
from the top to the bottom again
so the one-time use kind of makes it a
risk/reward where I mean obviously if
you can get farther in without using it
you can use it farther into the dungeon
and work there the next time yes yeah
you can kind warp that yeah any any any
yeah as you're progressing you can mark
as long as you have the gems for it
right you can you can set up those
little shortcuts there's other there's
physical shortcuts in the game as well
so as you play I'll show that hopefully
if I can survive but as you play and and
you know make your way through the
through the world and get deeper into it
you do inevitably find little ways back
you're you're always constantly poking
holes back up to the surface of the
islands okay so the island initially
begins as sort of like you know it has
only one path into the world but very
quickly if you if you're sort of
exploring around you'll find little
little ways to to pop little holes back
in open up little doorways that were
hidden and then eventually throughout
the game the island surface becomes just
like a multi path Nexus for the for the
game world okay
little foxes though those enemies
they're like hey like crystallized or is
that just like kind of the art direction
you're going for like the up fewer these
ones there yeah yeah yeah these this is
sort of this is sort of like the main
faction of enemies in the game and when
you if you attack them they they're the
main source of for the lantern no answer
so these little gems that you see the
big drop that's the fuel for the lantern
okay and the lantern burns fuel by just
having it on like I have right now but
it it burns a little bit more fuel when
you use the lantern beam okay the
lantern beam can be used to push away
the kind of fog of war here it also has
other uses as well just for like it's so
it's a magical device that has a whole
bunch of functions in the game right it
also reveals traps with those little red
glyphs like that so when you do lose the
lantern for example like this that
little detail there that red glyph does
something that when you come back into
the world without it that's what the
trap looks like okay look at it looks
like that okay I was just gonna ask like
like that so those are the two please
because whether those are the two
different changes and difficulty as you
yeah learn already lose the lantern and
get back to it so what are some obvious
I'm obviously this is a loaded question
because it's but you've got offended
working on the game on and off for five
years right yeah but what are some of
the major changes you've made in the
home stretch or or like say like since I
think I was telling you 2015 was the
last time I saw the game yeah at PAX or
something and I'm curious like are there
any major changes you made to the
formula as I hasn't been largely the
same since you you started the formula
has been the same I'm sorry okay
[Laughter]
I actually died fumbling with my
inventory so bad form but hey you
shouldn't say here's a protip you should
not use the backpack unless you're safe
because the game doesn't pause anything
okay so it's definitely good to do all
your you know backpack crafting and all
that kind of stuff when you've retreated
into some sort of safe zone right this
gives me an opportunity to show off the
the way the checkpoints work cool and
dying in this game is par for the course
yeah oh yeah right you've heard that
bridge last time right yeah so yeah I
can use this I'm gonna use this just
again and get a little bit more
resources but then I'll teleport from
the next fire okay Jim Guthrie who did
the music for super brothers sword &
Sworcery and planet coaster and rains
her majesty and a bunch of other games
also did the music for this game as well
it's great so you've heard that little
little return to island ditty there was
when you were in a camp by earlier
crafting was that it sounded like maybe
I was imagining it maybe just the
soundtrack playing but it seemed like
when you were combining items there was
like a reactive kind of music yeah
there's that that's a good catch yeah
there's a little there's a little
musical hand system I don't know if any
other items that I can show this off
with right now actually don't but
I don't have the items that I ex with
this but when I guess I'm like that but
yeah there's there's a little bit of
like there's a couple little notes that
if you're crafting it kind of hints to
you that you're on the right track or
you're not on the right track okay I'm
gonna use the return to shortcut let's
bring you to that one on those
zigzagging stairs okay cool
so the shortcuts are just one one use so
basically I have like one one easy
chance and it's never quite easy but one
easier shot to return to the the corpse
of the previous wander okay and to
retrieve the lantern and if I if I mess
up here then I'm just back to back to
the top and I I have to event I can
check my map here and it shows me the
vine lantern is a little bit over to the
right I've had a little red dot there
right and there's a corpse as well so
you can use the mini-map to to track
whether you know where the items are
that you're looking
she said you say screw up here you won't
you'll go back to the beginning and then
you won't have the shortcut right yes
yeah yeah but any physical shortcuts you
open up right like the bridge will still
be exactly yes okay so in this level
there's also another little hidden
shortcut of a managed to open that I'll
be able to retrieve to return to here
pretty quickly okay but well yeah I mean
the game does still have kind of like a
hardcore roguelike rule set so when
these sort of helpful shortcuts ever go
away you do and it's kind of back at the
top and the lantern never moves it's
something that is permanently in in the
place that's bad then you dropped it
sure so think about that is that the
game ends up being ends up sort of
very naturally becoming harder and
harder because if you get really deep
into the game world and lose the lantern
look Oh tell me after you kill these
good yeah I'll talk to you guys that's
that's a very early trap yeah it's just
sort of like intro to trap so if you've
run across this little trip trap it
trips you and it's oh just like if
there's anything around you you'll pay
for it yeah you can also cut it with a
little slash attack nobody goes I have
to do okay so it's just kind of like a
non-lethal
hey there's traps and you should watch
out for them and then after that I we
sort of start nailing you with the
lethal stuff such as that trying to get
you can also use traps against enemies
which is what just happened there I'm
not sure please yeah yeah that's a
little boy okay when when I attack that
enemy it dodged into a trap okay
[Music]
so the bot the corpse is in this area
right everybody I think the corpse and
the lantern right here okay
these little fire pits are these little
fire pillars right here they provide a
little bit of lights which is important
the game does get darker and darker as
you get deeper it gets colder as well
it gets more devoid of resources as it
gets deeper so this little cave area you
know growing grass and and this is the
Corp site you when you get to your
corpse you can pick up the lantern okay
you hit me all these achievements thank
you so much oh yeah and you can also
pick up all of your weight as well okay
but you only have one shot to do that so
after one attempt the corpse disappears
and all of its loot the spheres as well
but the lantern itself stays permanently
the lantern will always be here okay
yeah so that yeah the way to think what
is that it's it is it is kind of like a
little bit on that you're trying to pick
up and take further but like to your
earlier point if you get super deep into
the dungeon the lantern is gonna be very
far down so the game's gonna be harder
because you have to get that far without
the dungeon ii-era without the lantern
Lantern yet so there's a lot of
different Mechanics for lights like
there's obviously the torch there's a
couple of pieces of gear that also
generate lights but also if you don't
have any light at all you can just drop
your crystals on the ground and sort of
like just tippy-toe your way through the
game but if you noticed I also want to
kill enemies they drop light as well if
I don't pick up so right now I'm not
using any of my own light source okay
but just by not picking up the
collectables I yeah I can whoa
die super fast yeah just by not picking
up the collectables you can sort of
illuminate the environment that's a
really nice touch as well so the nice
thing about that is that really deep
into the game if you are looking for the
lantern you also pick up the ones that
you dropped as well but if for example
like if I don't have my turn I don't
have a torch or anything like that I
could still kind of go like
you know okay and then to eliminate
traps every like a grow under these guys
into my little light zone
he's not [ __ ] for it
and I'll just kill ya
fourth Italy if the arrows land anywhere
on the actual level you can pick them
back up so and the arrows are craftable
there's a whole bunch of different kinds
of bombs and flares and things like that
so the bow and arrow and and and the
sword and shield are are they're kind of
core you know and then around that
there's a whole bunch of different kinds
of gear and leaves and stuff like that
to help you and so you're saying of
course Cappy has released other stuff
throughout these five years obviously it
was super time force you worked on the
don't starve I'm forgetting the name
right now don't starve shipwrecked
shipwrecked yes yep
so you've been busy to say the least
yeah I mean I've been primarily focused
on on this I I helped with with super
time force especially at the ending
but the project dose Arvin okay kale
were primarily made by a separate team
and yeah so I mean thanks to those
projects this project was able to stay
in the oven a little bit longer so
that's generally how how we've operated
the studio we've always sort of had a
couple projects on the go and one you
know there's always like one project
that's the Cappy project and are lucky I
mean I reckon original project and then
every once in a while if we need it we
we do kind of like don't start was a
really great opportunity okay Kato is an
awesome opportunity notice as well so if
if it comes a lot if those things come
along every once in a while we do and
entertain working on contract work so
you did you work with clay much or was
it like the they kinda just hand off
don't starve to you like in its entire
yeah don't starship wreck was
interesting so they they they gave us
sort of free reign in terms of theming
the game and so the whole concepts the
shipwrecked concept and the sort of
mechanics in that was pitched to clay
and and and designed by by copy that so
we we came up with the idea in sort of
the the causes behind it and and then
they they let us roll with it
yes I was really really good positive
project for us there's some things you
know that we learns on that project that
overlap with this project a little bit
because this does have a little bit of
survival it's it's no it's this isn't
like a game that has like you know
extensive like endless crafting lists or
anything like that the crafting is
religious sort of a support system right
I'm just opening up another little
shortcut here
I'm really interested to see how like I
mean I can already kind of see like you
said like I can see it don't starve
influence on this and vice versa
chipwrecked but it's it'd be interesting
to see kind of how those different
projects might have fed into this
throughout its lifespan development
lifespan um the this game was was you
know midway through its its development
when we started working on don't starve
so the influence is very minimal okay if
anything I would say the concept of
shipwrecks is taken from this game right
okay
as a little threat like they're both
like thematically similar to this like
I'm sorry but uh but yeah the way it
sort of helped us is you know if you
ever spent time balancing
[Music]
a survival game it kind of it just helps
you think about the right things now
we're always be aware of and know what
to worry about
no no crafting opportunities here
so that floor key to the next floor down
yeah so the game's kind of structured
like some of the structure is very very
very classic every floor has a key they
need to find it as a door to the next
level and then within that level there's
also little secret areas but in order to
sort of progress downwards you do have
to sort of explore enough of the world
to find the key and to find the doorway
those are just kind of the very
fundamental goals on each level sure
find key findings that kind of thing and
then built around that or just a whole
bunch of weird little mechanics okay
is there any like lore behind the
relationship between the separate
wanders or is this just like an island
that draws people to it there's a lot of
background lower just in terms of my own
sort of world building and things like
that yeah but that's exactly how I would
describe it actually I'm going to you
know one of those sort of concepts in
the game is at least for me that an idea
behind these Wanderers appearing on the
islands I've always started to thought
about is like moths to a flame kind of
thing okay where in this world there's
this island in the middle of the ocean
that's guarded by these standing stones
and some of its energy seeps out and
afflicts Wanderers and draws them in
okay
that's the concept like that that's
never expressed lose a game in there
it's pretty little it's just yeah it's
just sort of some some humans are drawn
to those islands for one
and that's pretty much all you know now
there you go
did he just try to attack you and then
got you baited him into the yeah I sort
of just like knew he was gonna attack in
my direction and baited him into the
trial it's like he made this game yeah
it's almost a guy knew exactly what he
was in yet yeah you're skilled
I mean knowledge is is skill yeah so if
you play the game enough you can get a
sense for it like any other game sure
and understand timings of things how to
take advantage of certain things
I would suggest that players play the
game slowly and carefully yeah if you
were to run into you know like a crowd
of of enemies you're always only a
couple of hits from being completely
annihilated yeah and the game has a
bleeding mechanics when you do take a
hit unless you can fix that with with a
you know a craftable band-aid or
band-aid choice make that mistake I like
that it's like a band-aid logo in the
menus though right yeah yeah little
little modern touch yeah stylistic stuff
but yeah if when you get hit you do
start to bleed and so there's a couple
bunch of different ways they can solve
that you can craft you can craft items
and you can also cauterize your wounds
with fire as well rambo styles and then
do it yeah
very lonely game yeah it is I think how
that's that's one thing I'm kind of
happy with though I think there's like a
certain feeling in the game that that it
I think it captures pretty well how are
we doing for time um or they look
another five minutes something like that
or sure is there something you don't
want to show yet I kind of don't want to
show this okay I could go into a
different area or I could just play a
little bit longer I can just like it -
sure yeah maybe like a couple more
minutes
yeah so I think it was a good chunk
there yeah I'm not gonna go this way
okay but um there's one more area here
that I thought I could try to get to I
imagine it must be weird / tough demoing
this game because of how much maybe not
how much it relies on but because of how
much it's centered on letting the player
figure it out
I am also if I was you I wouldn't to
like I also wouldn't want to show too
much yeah I find that every time I'm
saying like I'm mentioning in details
about like how the lantern works and
what kind of stuff those are all the
kinds of details that I hope players
will just figure out on their own over
time just through experimentation or
through community it'd help and that
kind of stuff so I feel like it's one of
those games where like people say like
oh I wish I could go back like it breaks
my memory of Dark Souls and go back and
play it again for the first time or some
like I even Ocarina like before you've
discovered all those secrets yeah you
can't forget no matter how hard you try
yeah exactly yeah
yeah I recently played well I played
breath of the wild when it first came
out yeah and it was just such a delight
to go through that world yeah anything
about it I almost always want to play
that game yeah I played that game
without any quick travel or any UI or
anything yeah I played it for like 400
hours or something like that something
really insane you get along with a Rob
our video producer here video manager he
has put a lot of time to that as well
but I guess we all have but something
you guys put equal amounts yeah I
completely fell in love with that game
and it was just really nicely yeah to to
experience that kind of like you know
fresh Zelda world there's nothing quite
like it
it's fascinating because I feel like in
the time you've been making this game
like several like including breath of
the wild and even if some extent like
Red Dead Redemption to have kind of gone
for that survival maybe not a survival
focus but definitely have heavy survival
elements and it seems like a lot it's
funny to see like big triple-a
developers going for that now as well
yeah I think a lot of the ideas that we
sort of started out with have over the
years become quite prevalent but I think
that's good it just that kind of it just
means that people when they approach
this game fresh and
well did he spawn a little small I'm
honored no that guy came to think of he
was sort of crawling in there slowly
right
what out there
I'm pretty good this game yes
- yeah I'm actually I didn't notice I
was starving what what they're up there
there's a little like in the top-left
corner there's the survival interface
the way that works is that there's a top
element which is the heart and the heart
is your HP which is basically represents
like a a bottle full of blood basically
if you go ahead it drains blood and then
tethered to that is hunger temperature
and thirst okay so if any of those stats
go down then it begins to drain on the
heart okay and soup for example just
basic soup will heal will give you a
little bit of temperature like it'll
warm up a bit it gives you a little bit
of everything
sure but then within that crafting
system there's you can create stew which
is a little bit more towards hunger or
if you like if you cook with more meats
that's what that's when you get and you
cook with more vegetable as you get
broth okay
but then within that also there's magic
mushrooms and things like that which is
the way that you craft buff elixirs okay
and yeah cool that's sort of how the
batch that system works
look how about it after this crowd we
can call it a calling a video or there
you go that's a good way to end it cool
well so finally have a release date for
below from Cappy crispy Ostrowski and it
is December 14th Xbox one PC yes it's
coming out for Xbox and PC it's coming
out for Xbox X there's like a nice 4k
build cool and the game looks super
delicious in 4k
I was gonna say it looks amazing right
now - cuz it has like the nice the small
art style we obviously we started this
game before 4k existed so oh right yeah
one of the few benefits of working on a
game for a really long time is that new
TV technology okay and for a game that's
really you know small-scale it looks
delicious and
in 1080p as well it's nice and crisp but
when did you see it in 4k it's like the
little characters peg legs are like you
know super noticeable and blades of
grass
look sharp enough to shave with and cool
there's a nice unintentional benefit
it's almost like we we intentionally
made a game for 4k with without but
Chris thank you so much for stopping by
us below it comes out next week finally
we will all get to play it if you were
watching this thanks so much for joining
us you can go get below on December 14
the next box one Xbox one X and PC I
highly recommend it from everything I've
seen and we'll see you around GameSpot
you